こんにちははじめしたそうです
僕が悪いかもしれません僕が悪いのかも
知れませんっていうのも8今日の光さんの
動画のみましたタイトルこの動画撮ってる
時はまだ公開されてないんですけどひとり
さん dqn の動画はじめした腸炎切り
ましたって書いてるんですよ
[音楽]
hikaru さんなんでですか内容は見
てないんですけどもなんとなく想像ついて
いるんですよというかなんでこの内容はだ
プレミア感つけたんですかひとりさんやっ
てもたぶん僕が悪いんだと思います僕の
予想ですよ僕の良さなんですけど引かれ
さんに誕生日プレゼント
た買っちゃったんですよ僕の誕生日
14feb でひとりさんに
誕生日プレゼント何かちょうだいって言っ
たらいいものをもらえるのかなと光るさん
にクレープってもらったんですけど
わざわざ光さん僕のために帰り言ってくれ
たんですよヴィトンの人のサイコロセップ
ですね
オート例えば最高じゃないんですよ
ヴィトンな細工のだから相当高いんです
けど僕のためにわざわざこれを寸日して
くれたにもかかわらず半分なんですけども
私
控えさんの誕生日つっ体を返せしようと
思ってひかりさんが誕生日が5月の29日
も2カ月以上が経っております
まだ返してないんですね
これ僕が悪いですこれ僕が悪これはどう
考えても開始してない僕が悪いんですそれ
を切っちゃったで光さんにお返しするんで
これぐらいの日付を開けてくれますかって
言って壁さんがいいよって言ってくれたん
ですけどもそれにもちょっと間に合わなく
て後の次男で間にはまあなかったらもう話
をさせていただくんですけどそれで縁切ら
れているポイントちょいか電話してみます
強い縁切られました家はれてる人に出ます
のやばい色
[音楽]
ぽ女性0
あお疲れ様です
はいお疲れ様ですいっ
ひかりさんでーす缶
そうですどうされましたかちょっと今
9分が落ちちゃっててああ
で今日の動画で延期るって書いてあったん
ですけどマジですか
ああ見てくれました今っぷれいにゃあ公開
ぷになっててはい
んですよねー
やっぱり年間飼っ
あれですか何か僕がちょっと遅かったから
とかですかねー
あっすーうーんまぁちょっとねぇ
えっ
もうちょっと我慢の限界ちゃったかなって
いう
いやほんとにもう下げちょっとまたて
しまって
あのー一市長のことが好きもちろん好き
それは周りを止めます
でも好きが
スノー率取って a
逆に憎しみにゾーンになってしまったって
言う
なるほどですねそう
ひかりさんに部に入って僕の誕生日
プレゼント準備していただいたにも関わら
ず
日からさんのお誕生日に僕もご返ししたい
なと思っておりまして
いやーこれはもう本当にひっかけ南と北の
問題なんで打っ
皆さんに話すことではないと思うんです
けどひかりさんがやっぱり陰気にも車道が
出されたリズボクも出さなきゃなと思って
います急遽とっておりますちゃんと後で
ないんで謝っておきますそして
なぜなぜ私がこんなに惹かれさんの
誕生日プレゼントを出すのに遅れているか
といいますとちょっと
いい理由にはなるんですけども理由があり
まして本当に心からお返ししたいんですよ
ほんと光3型巨時間作ってくれて僕に
誕生日プレゼントくれたので僕はそれなり
にちゃんと期間さんにふさわしいものを
準備しようと思ってもう悩みに悩んで
ホント難しいんですよ
誕生日プレゼントって
めっちゃ当たり前なこと言ってますけど
安西プレゼントとか光さんと花の色の濃い
ユーチューバーさんて何あげたら喜ぶん
だろうとかすっごいなやって音悩んで悩ん
で決めたんですけど決めてからもなかなか
準備ができずに手続きとか所色を含めると
相当な時間がかかってしまいましてある山
がこの動画を出したタイミングで本当に
被らせるようでもした気ないんですけども
ずう見させていただきました
1億円
[音楽]
me
と完全に1億円が家にあります
[拍手]
th
[音楽]